behind the seal doors of an intensive
care room medical staff treat a patient
seriously ill with covert 19 baby
monitors used to communicate with those
outside
to avoid the need to move in and out of
the area too often
the signs on the doors here the
ventilators the sick lying on their
stomachs to aid breathing
tell the story of a unit dealing with
the second massive wave of the virus in
belgium
and this hospital in liege is at the
heart of the worst hit region
wallonia all of the beds currently set
aside for covered patients here are now
full
and doctors like lauren gerdeaux fear
having to make agonizing choices
what i fear is when the hospital is
fully full of
patient hospitalized and if we have to
to to choose
which patient is able to survive and
which patient is not that's
actually in my bed when i'm thinking
about that that's
that's what i don't want to be while we
were here a patient died with covid
there was an agonizing scene as family
members not allowed in the room
peered through the window the daily
number of cases in wallonia
inevitably means more icu beds will be
needed in the coming weeks
but staffing will be a major issue the
doctor we spoke to said many people are
now calling this part of belgium
the new lombardy referring to the
italian region hit so hard by covid
in the first wave and there are real
concerns here now
about whether the health system will be
able to cope
the red cross is now supporting the
effort in wallonia
manning covid only ambulances the staff
on board disinfecting the vehicles on
return
paramedics say they're seeing many more
young people in the second wave
and fear what the coming weeks will
bring
uh
in wallonia like the rest of belgium
bars and restaurants have been ordered
to close for a month
a nighttime curfew has been implemented
and people told to limit social contact
outside the home to one person but
there's a warning from the government
that if cases continue to rise more
stringent measures will be needed
well what we want to do is avoid a
lockdown it's not really
something we plan for but if necessary
if you have no other option yet that's
the only thing you can do
when you see that your hospital capacity
is becoming overwhelmed
then you need to take action and in the
last instance
that will be a lockdown many doctors
argue that drastic step
is necessary with the number of covered
cases spiraling out of control
they have genuine fears about their
ability to manage the situation
heading into winter michelle clifford
sky news liege
belgium